happy playstation showcase eve everyone
today we're talking about playstation
acquiring a new studio how there is a
small chance that the steam deck may not
play your favorite game plus blizzard
revealed why you won't be able to play
diablo 2 resurrected in true ultra wide
goodness my name is devonte chisholm and
you're watching gamespot news
for starters let's talk about
playstation acquiring another game
studio today head of playstation studios
herman holst announced developer fire
spray is now a sony studio this makes
fire sprite the 14th member of the
playstation studios family and the third
studio that sony has acquired this year
following the buyouts of return on
developer housemarque and pc port
specialists nexus software in a blog
post hermann said quote i couldn't be
more delighted to welcome firesprite to
the playstation studios family as our
14th studio quite a few members of
firesprite came from sie studio
liverpool and were thrilled to welcome
them back if you didn't know sie studio
liverpool was previously shuttered so
it's a homecoming of sorts for the
developers who moved to fire sprite and
are now back at sony adding to this fire
sprite's managing director graham ankers
also made a statement about joining
playstation studios and teased a new
project is in the process anchor said
quote playstation also gave us the
opportunity to create our own ip the
persistence and we were given the
creative freedom to explore innovate and
release a survival horror game we were
immensely proud of now as a first party
studio we know we have the full support
of playstation in furthering our
heritage of combining creativity and
technical innovation to offer some truly
unique experiences for playstation fans
we can't wait to show you what we've
been working on we're just getting
started hit the comment section and let
me know what type of experience you're
hoping fire sprite can bring to sony's
first party library
now let's switch gears to some portable
gaming news according to code weaver's
president james b raymie valve's steam
deck won't play all of your steam games
at launch if you didn't know
codeweaver's co-developed proton with
valve and proton is the layer through
which steam os is able to run native
windows titles on linux which ships with
the steam deck as you might expect there
are some cases where games will not work
as intended with steamos out of the box
with proton currently supporting around
16 000 games that are listed on steam
that's a large number especially since
it was only 27 games in 2018
but it's still not all of the games on
steam which might end up conflicting
with some of your purchases the
confusion about library-wide
compatibility seems to have stemmed from
an interview conducted between ign and
valve's pierre loop graphics in it
graphious mentions that the steam deck
will be able to handle all games
currently sold on steam something which
raimi interprets has more to do with
hardware compatibility than software
speaking on the boiling steam podcast
raymie said quote i don't necessarily
think he was referring to supporting
that game in proton i think he was
referring to that device has the
horsepower the video graphics the ram
and the hard drive space to support any
game out there
but i know those last two stories seemed
pretty important but nothing nothing is
as important as eating a bunch of
pokemon
in oreo form as part of the 25th
anniversary pokemon celebration the
pokemon company has teamed up with the
makers of oreo cookies to offer a
special edition version of the sugary
snack these limited edition cookies
appear to be the same oreos you know but
the wafers themselves are stamped with
the designs of 16 pokemon like the
trading cards is based on it appears
pokemon x oreo cookies come with
different designs in each package
encouraging people to buy more to
collect them all
and now let's talk about diablo the
diablo 2 resurrected beta has come and
gone and with just a few weeks left
before the full game's release blizzard
is offering additional insight regarding
certain features including 21x9 ultra
wide monitor support while the game will
be playable on an ultra wide monitor it
won't support the full 21x9 aspect ratio
instead only extending to 19x9 support
for 21x9 was included in the game's
technical alpha but was reduced to 19x9
in the more recent beta leaving many
players to wonder why and it turns out
there's a good reason behind the
limitation because
by 9 breaks the game specifically
playing at an ultra wide aspect ratio
makes it so that players can attack from
further ranges than the game was
designed for enemies targeted from the
extended range ultrawide monitors
provide simply fail to recognize that
they're being attacked and as a result
they don't react
but alright that is it for me hit the
comment section and let me know if you
plan on collecting all 16 of the pokemon
oreos as well as what you're hoping gets
revealed or showed off at tomorrow's
playstation showcase and i'll see you
then
[Music]
you